LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
priez à l'hôpital est-ce possible
peut-on refuser les transfusions ou
préférer un médecin homme ou femme au
nom de ses convictions religieuses c'est
vrai qu'une fois en salle de naissance
on a eu un monsieur qui a refusé l'accès
à tout homme pour l'accouchement de sa
femme
la laïcité est un sujet clivant abordé à
l'hôpital dans un climat pas toujours
apaisé le dialogue est difficile à
établir pour des soignants rarement
préparés à affronter les questions
religieuses on est en train d'expliquer
comment on va chacun de nous s'adapter
aux problèmes religieux des uns et des
autres on est complètement je pense à
rebours de la logique de nos
institutions
alors pour faciliter ce dialogue
certains établissements ont intégré des
aumôniers au sein même des équipes
soignantes
on lit avec eux un peu de courant pour
ma part en tant qu'homonie musulman on
lit du courant avec eux on fait des
invocations on est vraiment là dans un
côté spirituel la laïcité à l'hôpital
est-elle menacée face aux radicalisme
religieux peut-elle encore défendre ses
principes comment soigner tout en
respectant les croyances des patients
laïcité soit un font-ils encore bon
ménage c'est le thème de ce numéro
d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro d'état de santé on va aborder
aujourd'hui un sujet brûlant et
passionnel la laïcité vous le savez la
laïcité à la française garantie de
croire ou de ne pas croire également à
l'hôpital cela pose des difficultés
lesquelles par exemple quelques
questions qu'on va aborder avec notre
invité dans un instant est-ce qu'on a
l'autorisation porter le voile qu'on
soit soignant qu'on soit personnel de
l'hôpital ou évidemment un patient
exiger qu'une femme vous soigne et pas
un homme ou encore refuser un traitement
si oui au nom de quoi on va répondre à
toutes ces questions elles sont
multiples elles sont complexes
évidemment bonjour Isabelle Lévy bonjour
merci beaucoup vous avez signé connaître
et comprendre le judaïsme le
christianisme et l'islam aux éditions le
passeur c'est votre dernier ouvrage
c'est une somme qui fait référence et
pour montrer à quel point vous vous êtes
saisis tôt de ce sujet vous avez signé
il y a plus d'une dizaine d'années
menace religieuse sur l'hôpital c'est
exactement notre sujet enfin menace en
tout cas on va essayer de voir si
effectivement c'est encore une menace
c'en est une pas ça peut en être une
aussi bien côté patient que tes
personnel parce que les demandes sont de
plus en plus importantes pour l'ensemble
des religions attention c'est à dire
qu'il y a eu des hôpitaux qui ont été
par exemple envahis si je puis dire par
les évangélistes le problème c'est que
il n'y a plus cette liberté de
conscience c'est-à-dire de vouloir
pouvoir croire ou ne pas croire de
vouloir pratiquer ou ne pas pratiquer
dans certains endroits il est vrai que
les équipes d'aumônerie ne sont pas à
l'image de la patientèle dans certains
établissements on va y venir parce que
précisément on a un reportage qui va
nous intéresser et puis il y a des
exigences de la part des patients qui
mettront en avant leur demande
religieuse avant même leur prise en
charge de soins c'est le sujet le faire
religieux entre guillemet est un sujet
de plus en plus présent dans l'actualité
et dans les débats de société il touche
également
à l'hôpital j'ai dit que vous étiez
spécialisé depuis longtemps sur ces
questionnements là on regarde votre
portrait
[Musique]
Isabelle Lévy et conférencière et
formatrice en milieu de soins sur la
laïcité et les relations entre religion
et santé elle a écrit de nombreux livres
sur le sujet son travail permet une
meilleure connaissance du fait religieux
des rites et des croyances par les
soignants et par les dirigeants
d'hôpitaux
[Musique]
alors Isabelle Lévy par exemple dans le
livre que vous ayez écrit il y a plus
d'une dizaine d'années pour donner des
exemples des musulmanes qui exigent que
les prises de sang soient effectuées à
travers leurs vêtements un juif qui met
le feu à son lit d'hôpital avec le
chandelier pour célébrer Hanouka des
Témoins de Jéhovah qui abandonnent leur
enfant ayant reçu en urgence transfusion
à sanguine etc etc c'est vrai que on va
tout de suite si vous voulez régler une
question c'est que dans la presse dans
les reportages dans la formation telle
qu'elle nous parvient tous les jours ce
sont surtout des felliers à l'islam il y
a une certaine pratique de l'Islam qui
reviennent ce que ça correspond à la
réalité de terrain quand même oui
principalement mais pas seulement voilà
c'est à dire que les demandes peuvent
être de tout ordre et qu'il serait bon
non pas de mettre en avant une religion
ou une autre mais simplement de que
l'ensemble des personnels connaissent
les règles à respecter pour eux-mêmes
pour les patients pour les visiteurs car
actuellement chacun fait un peu comme
ils le sont et je dirais même les
directeurs et pourtant il y a des règles
qu'on les regarde tout de suite on a
fait une petite infographie pour les
résumer regarder
[Musique]
à la différence d'un cabinet libéral ou
d'une clinique privée l'hôpital public
est soumis aux lois de la laïcité cela
implique plusieurs droits et devoirs les
membres du personnel qu'il soit médecin
infirmiers mais aussi agent d'entretien
ou d'accueil doivent tous respecter un
devoir de neutralité comme toute agent
de la fonction publique c'est-à-dire ne
manifester aucune croyance et ne
montrait aucun signe extérieur
d'appartenance à une religion
la loi laisse cependant la possibilité
aux soignants d'exercer une clause de
conscience par exemple dans le cas de
l'IVG mais cela oblige à orienter le
patient vers une prise en charge adaptée
et reste interdit en cas d'urgence quant
aux usagers ils ont eux le droit
d'exprimer leur conviction religieuse
tant que cela n'entrave pas le bon
fonctionnement des soins les patients
ont le droit de prier de porter des
signes religieux et se voit proposer des
alternatives en cas de régime
alimentaire particulier dans la mesure
du possible mais lorsque l'exercice d'un
culte empêche la bonne prise en charge
et que toute conciliation est impossible
l'hôpital peut considérer que le patient
refuse un soin et lui faire signer une
décharge de responsabilité par exemple
dans le cas d'une femme qui refuserait
d'enlever son voile pour un examen ou
d'un patient qui refuserait une
transfusion sanguine
[Musique]
alors on voit les règles sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes pour les personnels
soignants pas soignants et pour les
patients on va s'arrêter sur les
personnels d'abord question simple
est-ce qu'on peut traiter quelqu'un ou
être dans l'administration de l'hôpital
avec un voile est-ce qu'on peut porter
le voile alors ni voile ni croix ni pas
que ce soit c'est aucun signe religieux
ne doit être visible donc ça veut dire
mais je ne vois pas non plus le
remplacer c'est-à-dire trop souvent
des femmes musulmanes vont remplacer ou
des hommes juifs vont remplacer la kippa
ou le voile par une charlotte nous il
n'en est pas question c'est je ne dois
remplacer pas rien je dois porter une
charlotte lorsque le soin le nécessite
et non pas lorsque j'en ai envie faut
pas que ça soit une elle ne doit pas
faire partie de la tenue professionnelle
un soignant l'infirmier un brancardier
un médecin qui s'arrêterait tout pour
aller faire sa prière interdit bien sûr
que c'est interdit mais je peux vous
dire que moi je l'entends régulièrement
que c'est fait sur le terrain et souvent
toutes l'équipe le sait couvre
comment vous l'expliquez ben c'est pas
mon problème je suis pas policier c'est
pas à moi de d'appliquer la loi
n'empêche que si on a un patient qui a
un problème respiratoire ou un problème
cardiaque etc qui a une urgence et que
il y a qu'une personne dans le service
au lieu des deux qui devraient être
présent et ben ça pose problème et oui
c'est arrivé et ben oui c'est arrivé je
vais pas vous dire oui comment mais
c'est arrivé donc ça veut dire en même
temps qu'on met en danger les patients
déjà on n'a pas assez de personnel mais
si notre personnel est en train de prier
non pas en train de soigner ça pose
problème toutes les religions mettent en
avant le soin avant le temps allons
allons jusqu'au bout Isabelle Lévy
est-ce parce qu'on le dit dans certains
cas d'accro à la laïcité dans d'autres
institutions est-ce qu'il y a une forme
de lâcheté oui
oui et puis il y a pas de vague
ne surtout ne n'allons pas dire à
Monsieur le Directeur Monsieur le
Directeur ne dira pas à la direction
régionale de la santé ne dira pas au
ministère de la Santé donc personne ne
sait réellement ce qui se passe sur le
terrain et quand je suis sur le terrain
depuis plus de 20 ans j'ai écrit en 2004
un livre la religion à l'hôpital déjà je
dénonçais j'écris en 2011 menace
religieuse sur l’hôpital qu'est-ce que
ça a changé rien on nous a sorti une
circulaire en 2005 d'ailleurs signé par
Monsieur Jean Castex à l'époque il est
commissaire de la santé qu'est-ce que ça
a changé rien du tout j'entends votre
colère on va en reparler on va continuer
à mesurer si vous voulez bien le
phénomène Alexia le perron et Sébastien
villa sont allés dans un hôpital de la
banlieue parisienne voire effectivement
comment les personnels s'en sortaient
avec se faire religieux regardez on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
à la maternité de Montfermeil c'est la
même règle pour toutes les patientes la
laïcité est abordée dès la première
consultation bonjour
alors avant toute chose je vais vous
expliquer
la Charte de la laïcité qu'on fait
signer à toutes nos patientes enceintes
nous sommes dans un hôpital public on
attend aussi des patientes que elle ne
puissent pas choisir d'être soignée soit
par un homme soit par une femme est-ce
que vous acceptez donc de signer cette
charte de la laïcité je vous laisse la
lire tranquillement
prévenir permet d'éviter d'éventuelles
conflits liés à des demandes religieuses
pour cette cadre de santé même si ces
cas sont rares ils peuvent parfois aller
jusqu'à l'extrême on va pas généraliser
mais c'est vrai qu'une fois en salle de
naissance on a eu un monsieur qui a
refusé l'accès à tout tout homme pour
l'accouchement de sa femme voilà il
avait bloqué la porte et il refusait que
l'anesthésiste rentre dans la salle ça a
été le plus extrême qu'on a eu à vivre à
Montfermeil mais c'est vraiment très
rare je vous dis une fois en 25 ans
alors avant d'en arriver là
la chef du service depuis 6 mois préfère
aborder le sujet en toute transparence
pour elle la laïcité mérite d'être
évoquée sans aucun tabou ça doit être un
travail en amont en fait clairement la
laïcité lorsqu'on en parle pas on croit
que ça pose pas de problème mais quand
on commence à creuser et à
questionner les pratiques des
professionnels de santé on réalise que
c'est beaucoup plus problématique
si ce sujet lui tient à cœur c'est parce
qu'elle vient d'un hôpital qui réfléchit
beaucoup aux questions de laïcité
l'hôpital de La Fontaine à Saint-Denis
avec plus de 90 nationalités accueillies
dans l'hôpital les questions religieuses
sont abordées quotidiennement sans a
priori ici en 2018 les équipes ont même
reçu un prix de l'Observatoire de la
laïcité pour leurs efforts de
sensibilisation cependant avec la covid
la situation est désormais plus tendue
dans ce service de médecine interne
occupé par les malades de la covid les
visites sont limitées alors comment ça
va aujourd'hui un petit peu mieux
ouais avec l'oxygène ça va mieux
face à la maladie à la mort les patients
ne peuvent plus être accompagnés par
leurs proches comme autrefois quand on
arrive enfin de vie par exemple et ben
les familles viennent ils sont plusieurs
il peut y avoir de la prière de la
musique de la chanson il y a les
personnes qui sont très religieuses qui
demandent à voir l'imam ou le prêtre
enfin cette place de la région du rituel
s'effacer face à la peur de la de la
contagion alors face à l'absence c'est
désormais le personnel soignant qui doit
prendre la place des proches droit de
visite était interdit et plus du tout de
visite et bah c'était un peu du coup
nous soignons qui prenons la place qu'on
essaie d'accompagner de rassurer le
patient du coup on était les dernières
personnes à voir le avoir le patients
qui d'ailleurs nous a vraiment
traumatisé en tant que soignant parce
qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de faire ça de
voir ça il arrive aussi que des
soignants aillent plus loin jusqu'à
assurer un accompagnement religieux
est-ce que c'est souhaitable c'est la
question que ce groupe de travail lancé
il y a 10 ans par un médecin en soins
palliatifs le groupe discute chaque
année de multiculturalité et de religion
cette année la covid pose la question de
l'implication des soignants dans
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie pour
certains cette crise change la donne en
terme de neutralité j'ai déjà le
témoignage de gens qui lors de
l'accompagnement de malades graves et de
malades qui vont mourir des soignants
qui m'avaient expliqué qu'ils allaient
prier avec eux je me rappelle une
aide-soignante évangéliste qui m'avait
dit qu'en effet elle avait prié très
longuement avec la patiente et que ça
lui avait fait beaucoup de bien que ça
avait permis de la soulager autour de la
table cet engagement ne fait pas
l'unanimité
on est en train d'expliquer comment on
va chacun de nous s'adapter aux
problèmes religieux des uns et des
autres on est complètement je pense à
rebours de la logique de nos
institutions si ce débat existe
aujourd'hui au sein de l'hôpital de La
Fontaine il reflète les clivages qui
divisent la société actuelle d'un côté
il y a ceux qui prônent les règles d'une
laïcité stricte face à ceux qui espèrent
une laïcité plus ouverte
[Musique]
alors ils appellent les vies on voit
cette cette patiente qui signe la charte
donc qui s'engage à respecter les règles
c'est gagné non il y a d'autres hôpitaux
qui le font c'est une bonne chose ça
leur permet justement d'expliquer les
règles entre autres bon simplement la
prise en charge aux femmes donc ce n'est
pas un choix c'est je dois accepter
l'équipe qui m'est donnée le jour où
j'arrive pour accoucher ou pour être
pris en charge mais c'est pas pour
autant que les établissements n'ont pas
de souci le jour justement où cette
personne sera arrive à l'accouchement ou
elle dit oui j'ai signé mais ça n'engage
pas moi je veux une femme et non pas
être pris en charge par un homme mais
attendez c'est marginal ça c'est pas si
marginal que ça alors c'est pas tous les
jours c'est pas toutes les personnes
mais quand vous avez une situation comme
ça ça mobilise malheureusement toute
l'équipe ça m'intéresse parce que dans
le reportage à la fin on entend un
médecin qui tempête un peu c'est pas à
nous de nous adapter c'est dit-il
sous-entendu vous trop loin dans la
recherche de solutions qui nous oblige à
céder sur les principes c'est souvent le
cas c'est le monde à l'envers quand même
en fait on devrait pas négocier
c'est-à-dire à l'hôpital il y a des
protocoles du soin il y a une
organisation de service et ce que nous
demande justement tous les textes autour
de la laïcité à l'hôpital c'est en tant
que patient j'ai le droit de pratiquer
ma religion sans jamais remettre en
cause l'organisation des soins la
planification des personnels et les
protocoles ça c'est la lettre après
quand vous avez quelqu'un qui va
accoucher vous pouvez pas la laisser en
plan la personne ce qui est très simple
c'est que l'ensemble des religions exige
contre transgresse tout interdit
religieux pour sauver son sa vie ou son
intégrité physique ou mentale donc que
vous soyez là pour un accouchement une
intervention un examen radiologique ou
quoi que ce soit la pudeur le problème
homme-femme et tout ce que le reste n'a
plus compte vous allez au Maghreb ou
dans d'autres pays les médecins c'est
des hommes
et ça ne pose pas de problème un jour je
me souviens j'étais sur un plateau télé
on a un auditeur qui originaire
d'Algérie qui dit dans mon pays il y a
pas de problème pourquoi il y en a en
France j'ai monsieur c'est toute la
question pourquoi il y a des problèmes
en France parce que justement on accepte
la négociation est-ce que parce que
évidemment l'hôpital c'est le soin et
c'est la mort et on se dit quand on
meurt à l'hôpital on peut avoir besoin
de ce secours spirituel d'avoir besoin
de d'un prêtre d'un rabbin etc il y a il
peut y avoir une aumônerie dans chaque
hôpital c'est quoi absolument c'est
obligatoire c'est dans tous les
établissements qui héberge obligatoires
qui héberge des passions parce que on y
vit il devrait avoir une équipe
d'aumônerie à l'image de la patientèle
reçue
et toute cette équipe devrait être
rémunérée et pas seulement l'aumônier
catholique comme il se doit comme
souvent mais excusez-moi les problèmes
religieux sont multiples est-ce que ma
religion accepterait que je suis ce
traitement est-ce que cette intervention
chirurgicale est-ce que ma religion
accepterait les antidouleurs par exemple
par exemple un antidouleur ça c'est une
des religions se posent des questions
alors le soignant peut proposer le
traitement mais le patient a le droit de
s'interroger parce qu'il y a des
questions quasi philosophiques dans le
rapport à la guérison par exemple est-ce
qu'on doit passer par tel ou telle
technique absolument ça c'est des
questions qui sont acceptées
sont allés dans un endroit très
particulier sous régime concordataire
comme on dit c'est à Strasbourg regardez
comment s'appuie là-bas sur l'aumônerie
hospitalière c'est un portage Sébastien
vilain et Alexia le perron
[Musique]
à l'hôpital civil de Strasbourg la
religion et la bienvenue
malgré sa blouse blanche Hanane Laurie
n'a pas fait d'étude de médecine mais
plutôt de théologie elle est responsable
de l'aumônerie musulmane à l'hôpital la
blouse blanche représente le soin donc
que ce soit le soin physique pour nous
pour notre part en tant qu'accommunier
c'est plutôt le soin spirituel la
présence auprès du patient première
visite de la journée au service de soins
palliatifs là où sont hospitalisés des
patients en fin de vie bonjour voici le
moyen musulman
on m'a appelé parce que vous aviez
besoin d'une visite il me semble
alors au même titre que l'équipe
soignante elle peut être appelée pour
assister à un patient
est-ce que vous voulez que je passe de
temps en temps pour qu'on puisse prier
ensemble pour qu'on puisse se voir pour
qu'on puisse discuter surtout en fin de
vie les patients ont besoin d'un
accompagnement spirituel et comme il est
impossible pour eux de sortir de
l'hôpital Hanane vient jusqu'à eux on
est à côté du patient on lit avec eux un
peu de courant pour ma part en tant que
monnaie mus on lit du courant avec eux
on fait des invocations on est vraiment
là dans un côté spirituel et puis
souvent il nous raconte une part de leur
vie un petit moment une étape qui les a
marqué et puis on est là on est un petit
peu la soupape de décompression salut
Perrine ça va oui ça va dis-moi
l'aumônier vient à la demande des
soignants des familles ou des passions
eux-mêmes vraiment cette volonté de se
rapprocher de sa spiritualité surtout à
quelques jours là au début du ramadan
tout ça ça vrai que ça réveille ça chez
lui dans des contextes un peu d'anxiété
de détresse quand on a des patients qui
sont très croyants très pratiquants de
toute manière on a on contacte
généralement l'aumônerie on prend le
patient en charge dans sa globalité pas
que dans sa douleur pas que dans sa
symptomatologie le développement
spirituel du patient ça fait partie de
ce qu'on de ce qu'on doit prendre en
charge en fait
musulmane bonjour entre deux visites de
patients l'aumônier doit aussi
accompagner les familles alors est-ce
que la personne souhaiterait être
enterrée en France ou à l'étranger elle
se retrouve vite démunis face à
l'organisation du rite funéraire donc en
fait il faudra rapprocher du coup des
pompes funèbres et à ce moment-là une
fois que vous allez voir avec les pompes
funèbres nous pourrons voir pour une
toilette mortuaire bon courage belle
journée au revoir ce rôle de médiation
avec les familles et les patients est
aussi là pour faciliter le travail des
soignants
oui on serait salut Françoise comme dans
ce service de pneumologie par exemple
ouais je viens de voir tu sais pour les
patients qu'on a vu la semaine dernière
je voulais savoir comment ça allait
au-delà du soin spirituel l'aumônier est
un membre de l'équipe qui favorise le
dialogue entre patients et soignant
effectivement c'est assez compliqué
quand j'ai discuté avec lui il
m'expliquais que il était pas bien qu'il
s'alimentait pas l'infirmière m'avait
aussi expliqué qu'il refaitait
s'alimenter qui voulait personne dans le
lit d'à côté aussi et du coup après
quelques discussions il me disait qu'en
fait il voulait rentrer à la maison et
tu sais on a la veille du mois de
Ramadan donc c'était assez compliqué il
voulait vraiment être en famille et puis
il m'a surtout religieuse est-elle
compatible avec la laïcité en France
l'existence des aumôneries est elle-même
consacrée dans la loi de 1905 de
séparation de l'Église et de l'État si
la République ne reconnaît nos salariés
ni ne subventionnent aucun culte elle
laisse quand même la possibilité au
service de Monnerie d'exercer dans
certains établissements publics comme
les hôpitaux
dans cet hôpital on a l'embarras du
choix on peut prier face à la Mecque ou
alors se recueillir dans cette chapelle
et chaque culte est représenté par un
homonier
il y a Jean-Paul Malo Dufour l'aumônier
catholique Anne Laurie l'aumônier
musulman Annick Vanderlinden l'aumônier
protestant et Harold de veille
l'aumônier israélite lorsqu'ils
échangent les différences
confessionnelles s'effacent au profit
d'un dialogue interreligieux
on fait vraiment exactement le même
travail on est dans le dans le même
accompagnement on est dans la même
compassion on est dans cette même
empathie vis-à-vis des malades et il y a
dans cette dans cet échange d'expérience
quelque chose de vraiment de très très
riche seulement en France toutes les
aumôneries ne sont pas logées à la même
enseigne à peine 15% des homonies
musulmans du pays sont salariés à temps
plein comme un âne
justement il serait bien que ça se tend
à développer sur le niveau national et à
l'instar de mon statut ici en tant que
money responsable de l'aumônerie
musulmane aux Hôpitaux Universitaires de
Strasbourg j'espère vraiment que
d'autres homonymes puissent avoir un
temps plein dans d'autres hôpitaux une
exception peut-être favorisée ici à
Strasbourg par la place qu'occupe la
religion au sein du régime concordataire
qui permet à l'état de salarier les
représentants des cultes
[Musique]
Isabelle Lévy alors évidemment des
aumôniers payés etc risque de
prosélytisme on pourrait vous dire
comment on contrôle le prosélytisme est
interdit à l'hôpital de la part de tous
donc les aumôniers comme les personnels
comme les visiteurs comme les patients
n'ont pas le droit d'en faire donc là
c'est très clair maintenant attention ce
n'est pas parce qu'on parle de religion
on fait de prosélytisme les aumôniers
sont là pour répondre à des
questionnements de patients ou à des
questionnements de personnels
c'est-à-dire moi ça m'est arrivé de
m'entretenir avec des aumôniers sur le
la pluie et le beau temps voilà si on
n'a pas envie de parler de religion
quand même que ça fait 20 ans pour
regarder ça l'hôpital est dépassé
l'hôpital a énormément de problématiques
à régler au niveau de ces personnels au
niveau du matériel
au niveau financier etc mais on ne peut
pas non plus laisser cette situation de
la laïcité s'installer parce que très
sincèrement ça m'amuse pas j'aurais aimé
que ce sujet ne soit plus d'actualité
parce que quand en 2004 j'ai commencé à
en parler dans les là c'est que ça
devenait pour moi grave aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas grave à 100% avec tous les
patients dans tous les endroits
certainement pas il y a des endroits qui
sont extrêmement critiques et donc je
pense qu'on met en danger des patients
et la neutralité plus largement de
l'hôpital public absolument merci
beaucoup Isabelle Lévy je rappelle votre
ouvrage en 2020 connaître et comprendre
plusieurs religions c'est une encore une
fois une somme et celui-là je sais pas
si on le retrouve encore mais en tout
cas bien sûr c'est une référence menace
religieuse sur l'hôpital écrit en 2011
il est encore de d'actualité brûlantes
merci de nous avoir suivis merci d'avoir
été avec nous et à très vite pour être
santé sur LCP
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgeen mutuelle santé prévoyance
vous a présenté état de santé
[Musique]